[Applause]
thank you
thank you thank you
thank you very much thank you
thank you conference
thank you very much
thank you Nathan and thank you
conference for that reception that means
the world to me a very very good to be
with you here today at Congress house
the real Progressive Alliance
and the heartbeat as you heard from
Nathan of a movement that is winning
where we need to win
and where we haven't won for decades in
all four corners of England in Blackpool
Middlesbrough Dover Medway Plymouth
Swindon Stoke-on-Trent once again the
largest party in local government
and
all of which I'm reliably told means the
real winner last week was Rishi sunak
a brilliant strategy a master stroke to
lose a thousand seats honestly even by
Westminster standards the spin last week
was quite something
but all that noise it's water off the
duck's back it will never distract me
from our ultimate goal you know when I
was younger I was a decent mid-distance
runner racing across Surrey in the 1970s
not actually where you might think it's
all breeding ground for Progressive
politics
but one thing any Runner will tell you
is that the hardest yards come at the
end
so make no mistake we are on track
on a path towards power
but there's still more work to be done
a lot more work to be done
and the toughest part lies ahead
we've got to show
not just reassurance
not just that we're better than the
Tories
last week's results show people they
already get that
the task now is to measure up to the
scale of change that Britain needs
demonstrate that we can be the Hope
working people need get our purpose our
pride and our future back
restoring hope for working people
it's a simple aim
but it's what we've got to be about
a politics that uses power to fix
problems not protest to grab the
Limelight
as my project
respect my guide unlocking aspiration my
cause
and the goal is for a labor party that
speaks for fights for and wins for
working people
but it won't be easy we've got to
navigate our way through Revolutions in
technology in energy in medicine and
with an aging Society even in Who We Are
climate change is a recipe for Global
instability the global economy the power
of the world is changing
there's a war on our continent
and then there's the state of our
country after 13 years of shambolic Tory
government
seriously
if you think our job in 1997
was to rebuild a crumbling public Realm
that in 1964 it was to modernize an
economy overly dependent on the kindness
of strangers
and in 1945 to build a New Britain in a
volatile world out of the trauma of
collective sacrifice
well in 2024
it will have to be all three
all three
and at a time when our politics feels
broken
when people are bruised by the past 13
years
where working people listen to
politicians who said we're all in it
together
but who made them pay for the mess
caused by the Banks
where they missed funerals weddings last
goodbyes all to save the lives of people
they will never meet while the
government broke all the rules that they
followed
and when as their bills their mortgages
their rent all went up
they were told
there's no more money for you
but that is for the richest one percent
and by the way you need to accept your
family is going to be poorer
conference
this is the territory of decline
the Stony ground where our project must
plant its roots the soil where we must
grow Our Hope
it's no wonder working people don't
trust politicians after all they've been
through
no wonder lots of people now think that
things can only get worse
they've we've got to turn that around
absolutely
that's why our project can't be surface
level
it can't be skin deep it boils down to
this the labor party will only restore
hope in the country if we once again
become the natural vehicle for working
people an agent for their hopes and
aspirations a party of the common good
now some people think that all we're
doing is distancing ourselves from the
previous regime
well we are but that misses the point
this is about taking our party back to
where we belong and where we should have
always been
back doing what we were created to do
we've been drifting away from working
people for a long time
and that's Unforgivable
that's why I say this project goes
further and deeper the new Labor's
rewriting of clause 4.
this is about rolling up our sleeves
changing our entire culture
it's our DNA who are we in it for who do
we serve who do we wake up in the
morning and fight for who do we have in
our Mind's Eye when we make decisions
and with the levels of cynicism in our
politics that let down the drifting away
the disconnect
our collapse in Scotland the loss of the
red wall this task
is going to be ongoing difficult
and enormous
it is if you like Clause 4 on steroids
and the results this week
last week show our work
is beginning to pay off
but look
it's much easier to lose the trust of
working people far harder to reconnect
it's not just that the problems the cost
of living the NHS climate change will
take some time to fix they will
we've also got to understand how a world
of change those three revolutions are
producing levels of insecurity that are
hard to endure
that if work doesn't pay if living
standards are falling bills are rising
holidays start to feel Out Of Reach
family life does feel more fragile
that when you look out of your window
and see your community changing High
streets brought it up fly tipping
anti-social Behavior drugs and crime
that does nor away at your confidence in
the future
but if you see an economy that holds
power and potential where the southeast
creates the wealth and the only answer
that's offered is redistribution
that doesn't treat our communities with
the dignity or respect that they deserve
and most of all that patriotism is about
putting the country first
about serving your country not just
parading its symbols like the Tories do
but that working people do need to see
your commitment to service
not some kind of patronizing contempt
for those who fly our flag
it's a project
that comes from my values
from my political core
that depends on understanding the true
worth of service respect and stability
and gets how these three values are a
precondition for Hope and unity for
reconnecting people with working people
are meeting their aspirations in a more
volatile world
service because it's the lifeblood of
unity a collective mission
people think politics is about vanity or
self-enrichment
we've got to show them the country
always comes first
that's why we had to change our party
show we want business to prosper show
that our support for NATO is
non-negotiable and that will rip
anti-Semitism out by its roots country
first party second
[Applause]
respect because people want a politics
that's done with them not to them
it's about lifting people up not
punching down
I've never believed that there's an
appetite for culture War politics in
this country
you don't need to humiliate people to
move your country forward
you need to bring people together
business and worker public and private
politics and people four great Nations
all pulling together all United in a
collective mission
a mission with priorities that are
contested debated negotiated of course
but where politics has a higher purpose
that we never compromise on
where we understand that a nation is not
just a country but a community
not just a collection of individuals but
a Cause
and from that
we all owe things to one another
like dignity
understanding
and most of all respect
this is everything to me and I saw how
feelings of disrespect weighed my father
down
chipped away at his esteem
I want Britain to be a country where
people don't have to change who they are
just to get on
whatever your circumstances however you
contribute whoever you are
respect
that's not just a moral imperative
I also believe it's a force far more
powerful than division
because when people are fully respected
when they feel their contribution
carries weight when they're able to
bring their whole self to their work
their shoulders lift up
their belief comes back
hope is restored
and then you put that alongside the
natural ambition people have for their
Town their Community their family
a pride and purpose I've seen in Spades
these last few weeks
that yes
we can build a better Britain
we can provide the secure foundations
working people need and get our future
back
but those two words
secure foundations
they tell us that the third ingredient
of Hope
is stability
it's always been a crucial part of the
labor promise secure jobs affordable
housing a safety net in hard times a
foundation working people can trust rely
on draw upon for their aspiration their
hopes the better future that they want
for their children
but I to be honest I don't I don't think
the language of stability comes
naturally to Progressive politics
I think too often we dismiss it as
conservative
as a barrier to change
don't mistake me the very best of
progressive politics is found in our
determination to push Britain forward
a hunger an ambition that we can seize
the opportunities of tomorrow and make
them work for working people
but this ambition
must never become unmoored from working
people's need for stability for order
for security we must understand that
there are precious things in our way of
life in our environment in our
communities
that it's our responsibility to protect
and Preserve to pass on to Future
Generations
and look if that sounds Conservative
then let me tell you I don't care
somebody has got to stand up for the
things that make this country great
and it isn't going to be the Tories
that in the end is one of the great
failures of the last 13 years
a Tory party that in Generations past
saw itself as the protector of the
nation and the Union
has undermined both
has taken an ax to the security of
family life trashed Britain's reputation
abroad has totally lost touch with the
ordinary hope of working people
the conservative party can no longer
claim to be conservative
it conserves nothing of value
or how rivers or Seas on our NHS or BBC
or our families or our nation
but the lesson for progressives must be
that if a tide of change threatens to
sweep away the stability working people
need
we have to be in there fighting for
security just as fervently as we fight
against Injustice
it is not our job to let your working
people that change is coming
it's our job to lead them through it to
bring people together and chart a new
course
use the power of government to help
support protect and lift up
stand as in times past with working
people pushing Britain forward in search
of their ordinary hope
thank you
that's what this project has always been
about
we've got to keep showing those values
show that service respect and stability
are Central to our approach
demonstrate
how a changed party could change the
country
that was the success of new lay by New
Britain
a modernized party fit to modernize the
country
that is our approach today a party once
again on the side of working people
changing Britain to govern for working
people
because if we keep to those values
understand how important they are to
Hope and put them alongside the
fundamental Progressive argument
that we will use the power of dynamic
government to push this country forward
then have no doubt this is a labor
moment
the conference that's what the future
demands
alongside Dynamic government you need
that sense of collective purpose it's
essential for our five missions for
everything we want to achieve in
government
it's how we make our street safe
tear down barriers to opportunity become
a clean energy superpower
build an NHS fit for the future and push
our country forward to the highest
sustained growth in the G7
and not just any old growth
growth that truly serves working people
that understands the need for stability
raises living standards everywhere
comes from the Grassroots
focuses on productivity in every
Community not just redistribution
see secure well-paid jobs that must test
of our politics
and puts communities in charge of their
own destiny
a new course
a break not just from labor arguments of
the past
but also from the traditional
Westminster model
this is what I mean by mission-led
government
and it's why I'm not afraid to use the
language of Take Back Control
there's no hope in these times for a
stand aside state
but at the same time nobody's going to
unite behind the traditional Westminster
way of doing things
walk around any working class community
and you'll be hit over the head by this
the people we need to serve no longer
have faith in an unreformed state
now speaks to a bigger truth
that the British public want politics
that gets the value of respect and
service
they want stability and change security
and Hope
and that's why I'm here that's my
project a new partnership between
politics and working people a new labor
project for our times a changed labor
party for a changed Britain labor back
as the party of working people that's
our approach that's what we're going to
deliver that's how we get our future
back thank you very much conference
thank you
thank you very much
all right